public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
eric woerth secrétaire général des
républicains est l'invité de l'épreuve
de vérité bonsoir bonsoir et merci
d'être avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de
public sénat avec l' afp les échos et
radio classique trois grandes questions
comme chaque semaine d'abord est-ce que
tout est acheté vraiment dans le bilan
de françois hollande qui va jusqu'à
affirmer qu'il à redresser la france
vous répondrai dans un instant à jean
francis pécresse deuxième question
pourquoi le programme de nicolas sarkozy
que vous soutenez est il le meilleur
vous le direz vous répondrez à guillaume
daudin enfin troisième question est ce
que la priait la primaire n'est pas déjà
plié est-ce que la prière n'a pas déjà
dit alain juppé continue de marquer des
points dans les tout derniers sondages
et là vous répondrez à mickaël szames s
mais d'abord eric woerth une question
d'actualité
les policiers se disent tabou ils ont
manifesté la nuit dernière les images
sont spectaculaires sur les champs
elysées pour exprimer leur ras-le-bol
est ce que vous les soutenez oui je les
comprends il ya beaucoup de
d'exaspération beaucoup de colère faut
voir qu'il ya 30 % plus en un an de
violence est commise envers les
policiers c'est évidemment assez
insupportable je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
totalement les moyens de travailler qui
sont épuisés comme les gendarmes
d'ailleurs il ya peu avec les policiers
les gendarmes aussi
et alors là un soutien les policiers
j'ai envie de dire quand même bien sûr
un personnel politique mais la question
concernait la manifestation en elle-même
puisque la hiérarchie policière et tout
à l'heure bernard cazeneuve au sénat a
dénoncé un manquement à la déontologie
ouais enfin la cgt peut faire n'importe
quoi dans des manifestations dans la loi
les conneries cacher et finalement ils
peuvent réitérer les choses donc moi je
je je pense que dans l'état
de fatigue et d'exaspération de la
société française
je ferai ensuite et le mini je ferai
attention à cela
pas de problème ce n'est pas la même le
relais pas l'arrestation
enfin il faut quand même que nos
auditeurs sache que les policiers ont
droit de manifester alors elle sert
peut-être faut-il autoriser que il ya
des conditions enfin ils ont le droit de
manifester mais pas dans ses droits dans
leur grève ils n'ont pas le droit d'un
certain nombre de choses ils ont le
droit évidemment de de manifester on
voit bien que c'est un mouvement
moi je crois que cette exaspération
cette montée de la violence envers les
policiers
cette perte d'autorité de l'état etc
c'est l'expression de cela comme un con
et derrière cela pourquoi parce que
souvent la justice dont l'impact est
acquis cette baisse d'autorités
gouvernementales et à l'état au
gouvernement
ceux qui nous gouvernent l'autorité elle
se symbolise quand la loi taubira a fait
a fait comprendre finalement aux gens
que que les délinquants étaient presque
la priorité du gouvernement puisqu'il
suffisait d'être condamné à cinq ans de
prison et ne pas les faire avec des
peines de substitution dans tous les
sens c'est un signal extrêmement fort
vis-à-vis de la délinquance est pas
vis-à-vis des victimes et les policiers
qui passent leur temps à tenter
d'essayer d'arrêter des gens ils se
retrouvent avec une chaîne pénale qui
s'occupe de choses inintéressantes ou
qui au contraire ne vont pas jusqu'au
bout des choses un gouvernement déjà sur
le plan des effectifs policiers que ils
ont rétabli eu un des policiers avaient
un peu partout contrairement à la droite
qui avait sabré dans les effectifs
oui c'est silence et skhira peut être en
boucle la vérité pas tout à fait cela
par exemple les gardes statiques
il y avait beaucoup de gardes statiques
on avait supprimé ses gardes statiques à
des questions c'est pas uniquement les
questions d'effectifs
il ya beaucoup de policiers en france
par rapport à d'autres pays donc la
question mais la question est là
l'emploi c'est l'émission c'est l'emploi
de la force
qu'est-ce qu'on leur fait faire et
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de gardes
statiques y ont été rétablies et ses
gardes statiques et puise fatigue que ce
soit les crs que ce soit les policiers
qui les mène dont s'est pas complètement
le métier pour faire des gardes-mobiles
lagarde dynamique et pas le contraire
on voit bien qu'il ya un problème de
chaîne entre police justice et que cette
chaîne a été abîmée par la garde des
sceaux précédente et dont on parle
énormément terre
mais aujourd'hui pour vous oui elle en
paye les frais oui elles payent les
frais dans un moment où il fallait
retirer l'autorité on a détendu
l'autorité les policiers ne sont pas les
seuls à être à bout à cran avec les
agressions violentes qui se multiplient
a notamment contre des enseignants ces
dernières heures dans le val d'oise en
seine saint denis des profs ont été
sauvagement agressés
est-ce que la situation est en train de
déraper ah oui a visiblement elle dérape
mais monsieur hollande de récolte ce
qu'il a semé c'est à dire du laxisme et
de l'inconséquence et de l'incohérence
à force de considérer que l'autorité
doit être systématiquement du côté des
plus faibles et on qualifie parfois être
plus fait tout simplement des
délinquants ça ne passe pas et c'est à
l'état de s'assurer
on voit bien que la campagne
présidentielle elle va apporter beaucoup
là dessus c'est que on est à la croisée
des chemins selon la schl les choses et
alors là on aura du mal à le rattraper
et en tout cas je sais où ça se
terminera c'est-à-dire à l'extrême
droite
ou alors on reprend partout dans l'école
dans les codes ce qui s'est passé pour 7
proviseur pour ce pour ce professeur et
pour bien d'autres est tout à fait
insupportable on peut pas laisser 5000
personnes sortir en décrochant bon il
faut bien réagir à tout cela il faut des
politiques en face on en propose l'aller
les républicains nicolas sarkozy ses
concurrents proposent un certain nombre
de politiques plus ou moins fort en tout
cas il n'y a pas de fatalité à laisser
la france
partir dans une vision laxisme devrait
changer donc autorité sécurité ce sera
l'objet de la deuxième partie de
l'émission tout à l'heure sur le
programme donc du candidat que vous
défendez pour la primaire nicolas
sarkozy met tout de suite c'est jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique que nous
accueillons l'épreuve de vérité
crédit classique et musicaux bonsoir
jean françaix sans michel bonsoir et
alors françois hollande comme on l'a vu
hier sur le site de florange appelle les
siens être fier du bilan de ce
quinquennat est ce que dans une certaine
mesure il a pas raison tout de même est
ce que tout est à jeter dans le bilan de
françois hollande mais sûrement quand 50
tout n'est pas à jeter on va pourra
faire un bilan a pu regarder et sûrement
eu des éléments positifs on peut pas
être dans la quartier caricature tout le
temps enfin quand on regarde quand même
l'ensemble du bilan c'est ça qui compte
mais quand on regarde l'ensemble du
bilan c c'est au fond est-ce que la
france la progression ou pas est-ce
qu'on est encore plus heureux de vivre
en france cinq ans après est ce qu'on
est fiers de vivre dans notre pays
est ce qu'on a donné une vision et un
peu de perspectives à notre pays
à ces questions la réponse est non non
on est moins heureux qu'il ya cinq ans
on gagne on a bien du mal à rattraper la
praille crise en termes de pouvoir
d'achat les déficits publics s'améliore
à la vitesse de la tortue les
fonctionnaires et les le secteur privé
sont toujours en lutte les uns contre
les autres parce qu'il ya deux poids
deux mesures les systèmes le système
social n'est pas équilibré bref on a
perdu sur beaucoup de tableaux la gagne
et on ne repart pas et le chômage
le chômage il est totalement hors de
fatalité au chômage de masse qui
aujourd'hui ne ne trouve pas de solution
et des points positifs quand même
l'investissement par le taux de marge
des entreprises est en train de
s'améliorer ce qui a pas un certain
nombre de choses aussi que vous auriez
aimé faire et qui ont été faites sous ce
quinquennat je pense au prélèvement à la
source des impôts paraît quand même nom
s'est enfin ça marche pas comme ça vous
êtes l'investissement
va mieux c'est vrai depuis mais depuis
l'année dernière il a été très mal
pendant trois quatre ans et un
quinquennat dans son ensemble c'est pas
parce que tout d'un coup ça va un peu
mieux à un moment donné quand ça a été
vraiment très très mal avant la vérité
c'est qu'on a reculé
c'est vrai dans le domaine des impôts la
surtaxation par tout le matraquage
fiscal
il sait il est passé au fond des
entreprises vers les ménages et tous les
ménages le savent très bien il n'y a pas
de cohérence une politique de réformes
c'est d'abord de la cohérence sur tous
les sujets on met en phase les outils de
qualification les outils de production
la compétitivité du pays le contrat de
travail
rien de tout cela n'a existé on a changé
sans arrêt de politique bon ben voilà ça
ne peut pas fonctionner vous aviez
changé
la tva sociale à la fin du quinquennat
c'était un changement un changement de
politique assez radical
c'était une baisse de charge nicolas
sarkozy a commencé par baisser les
impôts la crise est arrivée très
puissante très très puissante c'était
pas une petite crise comme ça une des
plus grandes crises qu'ait connu le
monde économique depuis cent ans on a
lutté contre la crise et quand la lutte
contre la crise sur laquelle ils étaient
franchement je pense un très bon
président de la république la lutte
contre la crise a donné ses fruits
l'économie internationale a commencé à
repartir la france a retrouvé 2% de
croissance et ont narré entamé un
processus de réformes est donc avec la
volonté transférer des charges sociales
vers la tva aujourd'hui c'est un système
moi dans mon avis qui ne peut plus aussi
bien fonctionné parce que ça peut pas
fonctionner quand on a remis 40
milliards ou 45 milliards d'euros à leur
fiscalité de plus par rapport au moment
où nicolas sarkozy avait pris cette
décision nous dit que françois hollande
a changé de politique sur le tard donc
il était de retour à florange hier comme
j'appelais le rappeler jean francis et
il a affirmé que notre regard devait
aussi échanger sur nous-mêmes en
l'écoutent florange c'est le symbole
d'un renouveau
il faut que les français regardent
florange avec ce regard là avec cette
fierté là parce que ce qui est en cause
c'est le dénigrement rituel c'est le
fatalisme c'est l'abandon
c'est la résignation c'est l'idée qu' on
ne peut pas empêcher le cours de la
mondialisation de se faire sans que l'on
puisse nous la france pour notre place
eh bien non est-ce que sur florange être
heureux l'avocat du diable un peu mais
ce qu'il avait promis en 2012 a été au
fond tony puisque les 629 emploi les 629
salariés de florange ont tous été
manifestement reclasser ou sont partis à
la retraite et la filière froide
fonctionne encore là bas il avait parlé
de politique industrielle les salariés
n'avaient pas compris tout à fait ça
enfin je l'interrogé l'est donc il
n'avait pas compris tout à fait cela
donc doucement je suis un peu étonné de
constater avec l'orangé est un succès je
sais pas si c'est un échec mais enfin le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est pas un
succès demander à la députée d'ailleurs
de la circonscription
lll vous le dire les mêmes sorties du
gouvernement en partie pour pour cela
retire moi je pense que la vérité c'est
que françois hollande n'est plus on peut
n'est plus audible
quel que soit ce qu'ils disent
aujourd'hui mais sur les tomber si bas
accor qui n'est plus audible pour un
président de la république c'est quand
même un problème c'est quand même un
tout petit problème pour quelqu'un qui
n'est pas président on peut jurer ça
pour un président de l'apic c'est
compliqué n'est pas audible
internationalement comme il lui demande
la parole justement vous pensez que
cette unité de leurs smaïl a vécu prises
il l'a prise
il s'est exprimé dans un livre étranger
et curieux il a revu beaucoup de vos
collègues pendant des dizaines et des
dizaines de fois et il dit des trucs qui
ne sont absolument pas compatible avec
ce qu'il dit pour le privé et le public
on voit bien que l'on voit bien tout ça
et il peut se passer
j'en sais rien je sais à la gauche de le
dire en tout cas ils ne donnent pas
envie oui mon avis que c'est un échec
c'est un échec total non jean sûr et je
ne suis pas que notre intérêt à long
terme et un avis alors lequel je pense
que je pense que l'ina ina peau fine à
une coche aucune case pour être candidat
à la présidence de la république
c'est un échec total aujourd'hui les
français doutent de sa compétence être
président de la république c'est quand
même à doutes assez profonds
il n'a pas respecté sa parole il a eu un
comportement le moins qu'on puisse dire
absolument étonnant donc je crois qu'il
faut tourner la page
budget 2010 est il est examiné à partir
d'aujourd'hui à l'assemblée ce moment
est-ce que voilà est-ce que ce budget
2010 est c'est un boulet pour la
prochaine majorité que vous souhaitez
être oui oui oui parce que ben oui parce
que il ya d'abord ce boulet ce monsieur
budget pardon il est assez factuel
factice et ça veut pas dire grand-chose
d'examiner un budget comme ça parce que
samedi électoral totalement
électoralistes construit autour de
l'élection présidentielle il ya plein de
cadeaux ce budget il y crée des charges
supplémentaires pour l'année 2010 huit
ans voit combien c'est difficile à dire
mais c'est au moins une dizaine de
milliards d'euros
donc ces charges elles vont elles sont
repoussés un peu comme de la poussière
sous le tapis et elles viendront obérer
le travail de la future majorité donc de
le vrai budget c'est juillet le vrai
budget c'est juillet 2010 est
étonnamment on a déplacé l'exercice
budgétaire de du mois d'octobre ou de
novembre au mois de juillet c'est soit
nous sommes de pouvoir et nous
retravaillons ce budget en fonction des
propositions d du candidat qui sera élu
soit nous ne sommes pas au pouvoir et
donc si ces socialistes il remettre
decker ce budget qui est dans des
hypothèses macroéconomiques assez
surréaliste et c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est le haut comité aux finances
publiques et deuxième point pouces
loin un certain nombre de dépenses qui
concerne pourtant l'exercice à venir et
anticipe sur des recettes à venir tant
qu'on aura moins de recettes en 2018
qu'on devrait en avoir on aura plus de
dépenses qu'on devrait en avoir
l'état reste lui-même d'ailleurs dans un
déficit important et la dette continuent
à progresser
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
c'est quand même pas très excitant dans
ce projet de budget il ya deux choses
en particulier il ya le prélèvement à la
source de l'impôt sur le revenu et puis
la baisse de l'impôt sur les sociétés à
28 % pour les pme
est ce que ce sont deux choses que vous
maintiendrez ou que vous réformer sur le
prélèvement à la source ou moi j'ai un
écart par rapport à ma famille politique
moi je considère que ces biens n'ont pas
de prélever à la source mais ce qui est
bien c'est l'objectif est de dire il
faut que en payent l'impôt l'année de
son revenu est en décalage avec nicolas
sarkozy un même temps en temps à mes
temps décalé l'aï dis que c'est un
flicage des contribuables notamment non
mais c'est pas sympa tant des îles le
diocèse de choses parce qu'il faut bien
qu'on comprenne ce que je dis j'ai envie
que le prélèvement à la source et le
truc qui va s'inviter sur la feuille de
paye et tout d'un coup vous allez avoir
une feuille de paye inférieur et par
rapport à celui qui paye pas d'impôt
tout à coup la valeur de votre travail
sera réduite donc le prélèvement à la
source est aussi un travail
supplémentaire pour les entreprises
c'est un drôle d'idée au moment où on va
demander plus de compétitivité aux
entreprises tant que moi je pense qu'il
faut pas faire de prélèvement à la
source mais l'administration fiscale
peut parfaitement bien vous mensualisés
sur vos revenus l'année et pas sur les
revenus l'année d'avant à ce moment là
vous restez bien un interlocuteur de
l'administration fiscale vous n'avez
plus une dette fiscale
quand vous commencez l'année et les
choses peuvent s'adapter comme cela
beaucoup mieux c'est évidemment possible
sur le plan technique sap a été choisi
pour le gouvernement gérait interrogé
d'ailleurs les ministres et
l'administration fiscale sur le sujet je
ne comprends pas pourquoi sur l'impôt
sur les sociétés ont donc on supprimera
la prélèvement à la source
d'accord le prélèvement à la source oui
d'accord elle sur l'impôt sur les
sociétés il faut baisser l'impôt sur les
sociétés au fur et à mesure mais je
pense que c'est pas la priorité
pour tout vous dire je pense que la
priorité c'est d'abord de baisser
puissamment les charges sur les
entreprises
transformer le cic eux baissé continue à
baisser les charges sur les bas salaires
soit débat qu'on peut avoir
mais sur les bas salaires parce que le
chômage est aujourd'hui situé est un
chômage de nom
qualifié doom sur des bas salaires il
faut voyez on peut pas on peut pas faire
tout et monsieur monsieur hollande
uniquement vous voulez pas non je les
entreprises moi je vois qu'il fasse
baisser les charges sur les bas salaires
parce que le les 5 à 6 millions de
chômeurs de notre pays ils sont
essentiellement des personnes qui ne
sont pas qualifiés qui sont donc dans la
zone de bas salaires autour du smic et
on voit bien que leur travail
malheureusement leur productivité elle
est inférieur au coût de leur travail
donc ils sont pas embauchés la 4e
caissière qu'on voudrait bien embaucher
dans votre supermarché pour vous éviter
de faire la queue bah on n'embauche pas
parce que le coût de son travail est
aujourd'hui supérieure à sa productivité
donc faut baisser les chats se veut pas
dire que dans un deuxième temps ça veut
pas dire qu'à un autre moment il faut
pas continuer à baisser les charges sur
l'ensemble des salaires mais essayons de
prioriser en france où priori jamais
rien donc question prioriser pour
essayer de faire en sorte que ce soit
utile efficace et là le gouvernement
dans son budget il saupoudre un peu
partout il met un peu d'argent sur
l'impôt sur le revenu il baisse une
partie de l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
certaines pme et pas sur tout est dit ce
sera à 28% dies en 2020 avant 2020 il
sera déjà parti depuis trois ans petites
questions réponses rapides sur la baisse
de la csg pour les retraités modestes
c'est une proposition que les députés ps
font pour ce budget 2010 est vous êtes
pour ou contre c'est déjà le cas
panel et les retraités ont déjà une
intéressante oui mais là vraiment monter
les scènes montées l'essonne englober
plus oui enfin moi je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de bonheur dans le domaine des
retraites je suis bien placé pour le
savoir
non moi je crois qu'il faut concentrer
les choses sur la reprise de l'activité
économique et c'est parce que y aura une
reprise de l'activité économique tout le
monde en profitera et leurs traités
aussi et je vois quand même que le
revenu des actifs aujourd'hui est
inférieur au revenu des retraités et que
c'est un vrai problème dans un pays qui
a besoin de durer c'est à dire que les
actifs ils doivent évidemment en
activité générait des revenus supérieurs
qui permette d'exercer après ce système
de solidarité dont nous avons eu
dernière minute par bojan français sion
sur notre dame des landes le premier
ministre manuel valls a réaffirmé sa
volonté de les évacuer par la force s'il
le faut est ce que ça vous rassure est
ce que vous êtes très favorable à ce que
ce soit fait dans les
jours à venir la raison demain suivant
il a raison ils sont allés au bout des
voies de droit déjà ça prend beaucoup de
temps il est inacceptable et des gens
venus tous les pays d'ailleurs ces gens
qui en rien à faire à cet endroit là et
qui ne sont juges des activistes
politiques qui prônent la violence
il faut qu'ils dégagent du terrain 7 cet
équipement était considéré comme utile
il faut le faire puisqu'il était
considéré comme et il a eu des années
des années d'études
donc il faut le faire et il doit avoir
le débat ségolène royal elle enfourche
tout les sujets les plus démagogiques lé
ministre des transports elle ne fait
rien dans ce domaine là on se demande
enfin j'ai jamais vu un ministre ne pas
occuper ses fonctions à les ministres
des transports on n'a jamais vu parce
que c'est un sujet trop difficile pour
elle et puis elle essayait d'aller
briller sur des plateaux pour essayer de
signer l'accord 21 dont elle n'est
absolument pas responsables donc il ya
un moment donné
moi je ne comprends pas qu'elle soit au
gouvernement monsieur hollande il
devrait se séparer d'un ministre qui dit
le contraire d'un autre ministre qui va
dans le sens contraire de l'action du
gouvernement présente comme la
vice-présidente paraît-il
si la vice présidente c'est à dire le
contraire du président est très bien
mais si le président dit à des
journalistes que ça n'ira pas jusqu'au
bout si j'ai bien compris dans le loyer
mais j'ai en tout cas non démissionner
je n'ai pas quelqu'un qui doit
démissionner si le chef du gouvernement
j'ai lu gouvernement il doit mettre de
la cohérence dans son gouvernement et de
lui dire t'es pas d'accord tu t'en vas
mais comme le chef de l'état lui-même a
mis en cause dans son bouquin de vos
deux confrères il a mis en cause
semble-t-il cet équipement se demande ce
que pense le gouvernement mais c'est pas
sur le sujet notre dame des landes c'est
vrai sur tous les sujets on peut pas
gouverner la france est également maire
de chantilly est ce que comme maire vous
êtes prêt à accueillir des réfugiés dans
votre commune qui viennent de la jungle
de calais j'accuse je reçois déjà des
réfugiés en provenance de syrie on vient
de recevoir quelques quelques couples
qu'on va loger chacun doit faire doit
faire un maximum dans ce domaine à moi
je pense que sur les réfugiés
non enfin il faut non non non enfin un
fou je pense que dans ce domaine là il
faut beaucoup reconduire à la frontière
à la frontière et et chez eux
la plupart des personnes qui sont là
sont des personnes qui ont été déboutés
l'équité n'est payant guerre
goûter palais je reçois des syriens des
droïdes monde ne reçoit pas donc je
reçois des familles syriennes
il ya le nombre de personnes qui sont
reconduits et a chuté cette année par
rapport aux années précédentes
sinon c'est pas normal voilà vous voulez
pas c'est pour moi je veux bien
accueillir je ne ferme pas la porte à
accueillir des personnes qui s'ouvre sur
le cliché ou fleuve sur le plan droit
d'asile et d'ailleurs je les fais sans
qu'on me l'a demandé
je veux juste que les choses soient
claires et aujourd'hui en ce qui
concerne cette jungle de calais c'est
pas clair on ne sait pas d'où viennent
ces gens la plupart ne sont pas des
réfugiés de guerre c'est faux c'est des
gens qui viennent de somalie d'erythrée
d'endroits s'est passé en tout cas c'est
pas le conflit s'est de toute façon tous
ces pays sont ralliés très violent il ya
des conflits un peu partout mais c'est
pas le conflit sira qu eric d'accord oui
mais ce devoir je devoir je suis prêt et
la population française elle est prête à
le remplir
je pense qu elle suffisamment de
solidarité et dans vie de ne pas laisser
j'ai pas dit ça je vous ai dit qu on en
accueille déjà je dis simplement que le
gouvernement
il devrait un peu mettre tout le monde
autour de la table et peut-être essayé
de demander aux élus locaux
un certain nombre de propositions plutôt
que d'imposer merci beaucoup jean
francis et maintenant c'est guillaume
daudin notre confrère de l'agencé france
presse qui arrive pour la deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité il épreuve
de vérité avec l'eye fi
vous avez choisi nicolas sarkozy dans la
primaire vous allez nous dire peut-être
pourquoi tout simplement son programme
est le meilleur pour vous qu'est ce qui
est peut-être l'élément clé qui vous
fait dire que d'abord c'est d'avoir
aussi une question de tempérament je
crois que nicolas sarkozy il a été
président de la république et que c'est
pas si mal de pouvoir bénéficier de
l'expérience d'un président la réplique
certains disent ah bah non c'est pas
bien vous pas revoir les gens qu'est ce
que c'est que ça on n'a pas envie de
refaire le casting ok mais enfin je
pense que au contraire une chance
d'avoir quelqu'un qui refait un parcours
qui est mon dieu se prend un nombre de
coups considérables que ne se prennent
pas les autres une campagne très
tranquille pour les compagnies leur
donne aussi à lui oui enfin la campagne
des compétiteurs de nicolas sarkozy elle
est super tranquille donc la campagne de
sarkozy par contre c'est autre chose on
lui fait passer un certain nombre
d'épreuves et finalement pourquoi pas
mais un certain nombre d'épreuves
extrêmement difficile donc il a le
talent pour ça il a l'énergie pour ça il
a l'expérience pour sa part ailleurs il
a un projet qui est extrêmement cohérent
et est très complet aussi à la fois sur
le plan économique en essayant
d'équilibrer parce que je pense qu'il
faut mettre beaucoup sur la
compétitivité des entreprises
il le feu 34 milliards d'euros c'est ce
qu'ont priseur etc etc
mais il le fait aussi sur l'impôt sur le
revenu c'est un sujet qu'on a on a
discuté évidemment ensemble il estimé et
je pense qu'il a raison
j'ai cette expérience aussi c'est qu'il
faut quand même c'est très difficile de
dire aux français qu'ils ont été quand
même matraquer fiscalement les ménages
qu'au fond on veut réduire les impôts
mais pas pour ceux qui ont vu leurs
impôts augmenter
il est assez compliqué expliqué il faut
beaucoup de cohérence si c'est pas
cohérent
si vous dites des trucs qui sont
contradictoires alors l'effort que vous
demandez eh bien il n'est pas à mener ou
en tout cas il est si mal perçues qui a
des blocages
je prends l'exemple de la tva et sa
oppose nicolas sarkozy à ses
compétiteurs
françois fillon comme alain juppé
propose des augmentations de tva c'est
assez compliqué de dire à nos
concitoyens
on arrive on veut baisser les impôts
parce que les impôts ont été trop
fortement augmenté mais vous inquiétez
pas on augmente la tva à ses
contradicteurs débat interne au sein de
cette primaire vu de l'extérieur vu de
la gauche vu je vais même vous citer
alain madelin
ancien ministre de l'économie de votre
camp très libéral en juin il disait au
point le programme des candidats à la
primaire c'est une caricature du
libéralisme qui apparaît comme une purge
patronale vous pensez je ne veux pas ce
que ça veut dire alain madelin il est
d'abord pas qualifié pour ça il était
ministre pendant trois mois et il est
totalement échoué
elle sait pas c'est pas le sujet je
pense que le sujet c'est de savoir oui
mais le débat il était de bonne qualité
et ce qui est une tolérance
vous nous dites est ce que finalement
est ce qu'on est capable de proposer des
trucs précis où est-ce qu'on veut créer
créer des plans sur la comète
on propose des choses précises chaque
candidat dit des choses précises donc
ces choses dans le domaine de l'économie
on a l'habitude de dire ouais mais ils
pensent tous la même chose pas tout à
fait le dessin sans en parler mais il ya
un certain nombre d'observateurs vos
opposants aussi évidemment qui trouve
que c'est un absolu remettre de cheval
pour l'économie française
non parce que si vous considérez que les
communes françaises et le marche bien
bas faut me le dire et puis il faut
surtout faire une dépêche tout de suite
mais je pense que et non plusieurs
méthodes pour re non je ne crois pas
première partie je crois pas je pense
qu'il n'y a pas à multitude de il faut
faire ce qui a marché dans d'autres pays
on dit toujours les allemands les
allemands formidable les anglais à un
moment donné formidable regardez ils ont
aujourd'hui récupérer une économie
plutôt en bonne santé bas où ils sont
passés par des preuves que nous nous
sommes au fond exonéré d'ailleurs droite
et gauche compris nicolas sarkozy
propose alors ses mots c'est vous le
spécialiste à la fois des chiffres de
nicolas sarkozy et l'ancien ministre du
budget il propose 100 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur les dépenses de l'état
ouais on est on est à combien
actuellement dépenses de l'état on est à
dans le budget actuel on est autour de
350 enseignants dont un tiers de dépens
des 100 milliards sur l'ensemble de la
sphère publique
d'accord donc c'est pas 100 milliards
souhaiter à ces 100 milliards sur
l'ensemble de la sphère publique mais
elle ya l'état la sécurité sociale et
les collectivités locales c'est à dire
sur une dépense qui est de l'ordre de
1250 milliards d'euros corps donc c'est
on va dire un douzième à ce niveau là on
n'est plus tellement déjà dans le
rabotage en est il fan ans fait du rab
ou voilà ah non mais on est toujours
fait nous on a fait la fille du ragot
qui sait pas du rabot c'est quoi ce
changement de politique c'est des
réformes structurales cédé qu'au fond on
leur disait structurelles
je sais pas il faut baisser la dépense
publique c'est l'intérêt national c'est
l'intérêt du pays il faut baisser la
dépense julie elle est aujourd'hui à 56
ou 57 % de vivre selon qui ont calculé
que les crédits d'impôts ou pas les
crédits d'impôts mais
c'est trop elle et les pays de l'union
européenne et la zone euro il tourne à
moins de 50
donc on voit bien qu'on peut pas avec un
tel boulet alors ce boulet ça devient
une bouée de sauvetage
quand il une grande crise ça a été le
cas on a plongé un peu moins et puis on
avait un bon président de la république
quand on a un mauvais président de la
république et plus debout et de sauver
plus de crise balles 7 ça devient un
handicap majeur ça vous entraîne vers le
fond il ya moins de consommation
il ya moins d'investissement pour
relancer l'investissement et la
consommation faut prendre moins d'argent
aux français aux entreprises françaises
et aux ménages français et ça passe par
une réduction de la dépense publique
dans le déclaratif on n'est pas dans le
coup de rabot mais alors du coup pour
réaliser ça est ce que justement faire
des économies structurelles est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un moment où vous seriez
obligés de couper vraiment dans des
actions de l'état dans des missions de
l'état pour pouvoir réaliser ces 100
millions d'économie nationale et à ckoi
600 milliards c'est d'abord c'est à peu
près 50 milliards sur la sur le budget
sur le budget social le budget social de
la france et 650 vous avez une relation
solide et on propose une allocation
unique dans lequel qui sera versée sous
condition qui sera plafonné en fonction
du smic pour toujours donné intérêt à
travailler parce que il faut il faut que
les il faut il faut aider nos
concitoyens qui ont des problèmes ça
peut nous arriver à tous
ce filet de sécurité il est absolument
indispensable la protection sociale la
sécurité sociale ne sont pas discutables
ce qui peut être discutable c'est la
manière dont sept employés c'est aux
fins aussi l'argent qui est consacré et
on voit bien que les français soient pas
plus heureux pour autant alors les
automates à travailler madère le doit à
son travail
récemment cité en exemple margaret
thatcher en dix ans mais personne à
droite n'ose s'en revendiquer vous aussi
mais je fin je le sais mon nez dans les
poncifs l'âme parfois je sais pas si
c'est cette girouette je dis simplement
par rapport au pays
il ya trop de dépenses sociales il faut
réduire ses dépenses sociales qui
resteront extrêmement levier qui
resteront extrêmement importante
il faut revoir l'assurance maladie et
des noms on propose plein de choses il
faut revoir
d'accord la retraite
j'en ai suffisamment payé les
conséquences dont il faut revoir la
retraite pour faire quelque chose qui
continue à 100 aussi sérieux que ce que
nous avons fait et puis il faut prévoir
l'indemnisation du chômage c'est
difficile à expliquer mais si on a la
dégressivité de l'indemnisation du
chômage
alliée à des politiques de formation est
alliée à une politique de croissance
c'est ce qu'on fait beaucoup d'autres
pays on restera toujours plus généreux
que d'autres et puis après il ya ces 50
milliards sur le social il ya une
vingtaine de milliards sur la fonction
publique fonction publique d'état comme
fonction publique territoriale
je vais je n'ai pas le temps de
détailler et puis à la prolongation les
rues de là c'est la rupture promise
vous n'avez pas fait oui enfin en 2007
on a fait l'autonomie des universités on
a fait la réforme des retraites on a
combattu pendant trois ans la crise que
tout le monde a oublié enfin sur ceux
qui en ont subi les conséquences vous
avec le le pipe de la france ils
commencent à revenir aux ailes son
ministre et aloses nicolas sarkozy comme
ses adversaires là où ses concurrents à
la primaire de la droite c'est des
pelletées de fonctionnaires en moins
nicolas sarkozy ces trois irait pas des
pelletées c'est pas sympa pour les
fonctionnaires ces reports s'il ya trop
de fonctionnaires voilà il ya trop de
fonctionnaires en france et pas assez
bien payé donc on avait commencé à les
réduire on a fait 150 milles sur l'état
et collectivités locales ont compensé la
chose malheureusement mais on a fait ce
qu'on a dans un moment où voilà il ya
quelques ya des craintes ou même des la
mondialisation fait des choses
difficiles contre es qui sont pas dans
une demande de plus de services publics
et la réforme c'est l'espoir réformer
c'est l'espoir ne rien faire c'est le
chômage
il faut redresser notre pays il faut
aller au bout des réformes des réformes
dans le regard de fonctionner récemment
cadre de notre pacte social moi je suis
pas en train de dire qu'il faut briser
faire table rase françois hollande
manuel valls encore aujourd'hui devant
les parlementaires de la commission qui
dit le programme commun la droite va
mettre à bas notre modèle social
oui enfin bon c'est des paroles
politiques qui veulent rien dire mettre
à bas le modèle social français c'est 6
millions de chômeurs mettre à bas le
modèle social français
ces titres est partout mais trabal
c'est de faire que les jeunes il
considère que l'avenir il est en dehors
de france et ça c'est pas nicolas
sarkozy
c'est assez françois hollande manuel
valls monsieur ayrault et plein d'autres
donc il ya quand même des limites
à l'hypocrisie est une hypocrisie
socialiste aujourd'hui qui est
totalement insupportable qui est
insupportable
donc on doit revenir à quelque chose de
sain quelque chose de sérieux
faire en sorte que la france reste la
france qu'on soit toujours solidaires
les uns des autres mais dans des
conditions de responsabilité je crois à
la responsabilité collective mais je
crois surtout à la responsabilité
individuelle et quand il ya trop de
responsabilité collective
alors tout le monde s'exonère de sa
rentabilité en question au passage il ya
eu aussi un certain nombre de critiques
sur le débat de la primaire où il a été
dit en fait en première partie notamment
sur les questions économiques c'était un
débat de boutiquier de comptable je
retire 100 milliards ici 90 milliards
ici peut-être ça manquait un peu de de
vision plus générale d'une expression
d'une vision que générale de ce que
c'était que l'avenir la france mais la
vision c'est une france qui est
totalement dans l'innovation qui fait en
sorte que ces facteurs de production ce
qui nous permet de produire c'est à dire
le travail le capital innovation le
numérique soit au mieux c'est pas le cas
d'une france qui croit dans ces
entreprises
tout ça une fois qu'on a dit ça je suis
pas sûr qu on nous croit on doit nous
croire sur des mesures précises
on nous a trop dit ah ouais mais alors
vous n'y a pas de mesures précises et
quand on fait quand on donne des mesures
précises tout très important que les
gens ils veulent savoir combien d'impôts
donc sur leurs revenus ils vont payer
veulent savoir comment le capital va
être taxés ils veulent savoir si on va
maintenir ou palier sf ils veulent
savoir le salon tiendrait beaux arts
mais s'ils veulent savoir s'il obtiendra
de promesses il est derrière ce coup ci
ajoute meilleur pour la meilleure façon
de tenir deux promesses et aussi d'être
précis dans ce qu on leur promet alors
que c'est ça qu'ils veulent
et après on nous reproche d'être trop
précis non on a beaucoup travaillé tout
c'est tout de suite servi au service
d'une vision du pays dans l'europe et
cette vision du pays
ce sera l'expression évidemment de nos
candidats aux primaires surtout du
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
parmi les mesures précises il y à
l'organisation de référendums sont
guillaume com
sur la rétention administrative des
fiches et le regroupement familial est
possible d'écouter ce qu'en pense le
professeur de droit constitutionnel jean
philippe derosier voulu répondre et on
ne peut pas faire un référendum sur
n'importe quel sujet on peut faire un
référendum sur l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics sur la politique
économique social et environnemental de
la nation et les services publics qui y
concourent
et pour la ratification d'un traité
international
les référendum suggéré voulu par nicolas
sarkozy concerne le regroupement
familial le droit au regroupement
familial et l'internement administratif
des fiches et sc2 question ne relève
d'aucun des sujets prévus par l'article
11 ce n'est pas l'organisation des
pouvoirs publics ce n'est pas la
ratification l'a traité international et
ce n'est pas plus la politique
économique social et environnemental de
la nation donc il n'est pas
constitutionnel d'organiser ces
référendum face et son opinion et vous
prendrez d'autres opinions ils vous
diront le contraire
donc ça par exemple n'est pas plus bête
il a peut-être plus d'expérience que
monsieur desrosiers était président de
la république au fond ça compte quand
même aussi à répondre à baisser sans
arrêt les politiques ça commence à bien
faire un lien émotionnel il est il est
important de considérer pourquoi
pourquoi le référendum est pourquoi sur
ces deux questions parce que ces deux
questions
elle forme politique polémique et parce
que c'est des questions elles sont au
fond un peu au coeur de cette campagne
sur la lutte contre l'autre curieuse a
eu pour l'autorité et sur la lutte
contre le résultat la question de la
légitimité de faire céder nicolas
sarkozy sait mais j'ai raison possible
de le faire oui bien sûr que c'est
possible et il a envie de dire et je
pense que c'est habile de le faire il
dit on nous dit tout le temps qu'on ne
croit pas est-ce que vous allez le faire
sur la même que celle que vous êtes de
ceux de la meilleure façon web a de
toutes les candidatures est ce qu'ils
vont faire escale à genève a pu
réveiller on peut oui mais c'est le
tribut à payer pour les anciens plus
aussi pour tout ceux qui ont un
gouvernement reste vrais pour la gauche
comme c'est vrai pour la droite encore
qu'à une pierre dans le jardin maraîcher
la même journée on parle pierre dans le
jardin d'alain juppé je dis simplement
que tout le monde a exercé des
responsabilités et tout le monde a
d'ailleurs été content des
responsabilités qu'il exerçait sous
nicolas sarkozy
entre parenthèses je dis simplement que
ces deux questions elles peuvent être
posées directement au peuple français
comme ça on vous demandera pas est ce
que vous allez faire
bah vous allez faire puisque le
référendum une législatif donc on dit
aux jambes a en même temps un goûter
pour les légistes
heures vous votez en deux mesures qui
sont des mesures emblématiques et qui
sont des mesures qui ne font non pas de
consensus mais c'est l'imposture baisser
l'impôt sur les sociétés un consensus
est pas la peine de faire à la fin merci
c'est très beau livre c'est l'homme à
laisser écrit michael izza des as mais
ce qui arrive maintenant dans la
dernière partie de l'épreuve de vérité
on s'en fichait bonsoir alors à ce cas
n'avait pas déjà gagner cette primaire
c'est ce que c'est plié
alors non enfin je vous hésitez enfin je
suis pas je le dis et comment je vais
répondre à ça la primaire est dans un
mois les sondages certains sondages sont
en faveur d'alain juppé au quai des
sondages eric woerth
oui 41 29
pour alain juppé au premier tour 61 39
au deuxième tour l'écart plus les jours
arrivent et pourrir en dit vous verrez
ça se resserrera et vous verrez que
ramener chez vous verrez qu'il y aura
des surprises balle jour de l'élection
et d'ailleurs ces sondages
systématiquement c'est sur l'ensemble de
la population
est ce une population qui s'estiment
aller voter puis à départ de gauche et
départ de tous quand vous regardez le
coeur de l'électorat de la primaire de
droite mais du centre - le choeur de
nicolas sarkozy est systématiquement
vainqueur donc on verra on verra bien
moi je pense qu'il faut mais il faut
continuer la campagne telle qu'elle est
il faut dire aux français ce que nous
souhaitons pour le pays
nicolas sarkozy doit le faire les autres
candidats doivent le faire et puis in
fine et les français ils voteront les
français de droite et les français du
centre yves voterons pas ce que vous
n'allez pas les autres est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas de malaise va causer
non je suis moi j'ai aucune inquiétude
je peux vous assurer que je suis
extrêmement zen on maintient la campagne
allait elle est puissante
il est partout sur le terrain il ya du
monde dans toutes les salles plus de
monde que pour quiconque je n'ai aucune
inquiétude
la qualité de ces propositions est fort
tout ça ce se verra moi j'ai pas
d'adversaire dans cette dans cette
campagne je voterai pour le vainqueur de
toute façon sans état d'âme mais je
soutiendrai le vainqueur dès le soir du
second tour et je ferai sa campagne
évidence et les règles de la primaire
est gelée elles sont extrêmement
importantes je n'ai aucune question là
dessus je dis simplement que je pense
que nicolas et nicolas sarkozy est le
meilleur candidat
sauf que évidemment comme il est la
cible de tout le monde c'est nettement
plus simple je pense que la campagne de
tous les autres candidats est une
campagne assez simple au fond il ya
jamais de coup personne ne dit jamais
rien donc chacun y va de sa petite cette
petite campagne est d'accord nicolas
sarkozy est plus compliqué anti sarkozy
est plus compliqué oui il ya beaucoup de
ça sarkozy et une au mini cible au fond
et les équipes de tout le monde c'est
ainsi que des médias si absolument tout
dès qu'il dit quelque chose s'il bat un
mouvement de cl c'est pas comme ça qu'il
fallait faire il fallait battre l'autre
cible tout et tout est très très analysé
bon on verra vous lever beaucoup roulent
a quand même c'est parce que c'est la
vérité et ses vérités donc on verra bien
on verra bien c'est une campagne
puissante cette campagne puissante elle
portera ses fruits moi j'ai pas de doute
là dessus
alors vous avez dit il ya un instant que
vous appelez les électeurs de droite et
du centre afrique et j'ai bien compris
que vous avez oublié ceux de gauche
n'ont pas leur place dans cette primaire
écouter ce que dit alain juppé au sujet
de la participation éventuelle ou
confirmés selon certains sondages 10%
dit-on d'électeurs de gauche à la
primaire de droite et du centre nous
avons voulu des primaires ouvertes il
faut l'assumer
je vois d'ailleurs que negro sarkozy
fait mieux que moi dans l'électorat du
front national dit ce qu'on va faire des
devis n'a pas fait appel aux électeurs
du front national j'ai pas fait appel
aux électeurs de gauche qu'est ce que
c'est que cette histoire ne fut un trail
aux électeurs de la droite et du centre
socialiser électeurs déçus du
hollandisme souvent des électeurs déçus
du sarkozysme
si monsieur kouchner vient voter par
exemple en disant j'ai été ministre de
nicolas sarkozy
qu'est ce qu'on va faire alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait les électeurs du lait les
électeurs déçus du sarkozysme sont des
électeurs déçus du gouvernement dans son
ensemble
1 je veux que tout le monde a été
ministre et ministre est très important
à tous les moments donc je vraiment
c'est important à dire le cac est là il
est propriété de tous ceux qui ont
participé personne n'est parti en
claquant la porte ce serait différent
personne n'est parti en claquant la
porte donc à ja je pense sur le
quinquennat nicolas sarkozy une
cohérence donc je non je pense que je
pense qu'à des appels du pied
voilà globalement il ya des appels du
pied sur les électeurs de gauche disant
vous êtes déçu par françois hollande
venez donc voté pour nous d'ailleurs
qu'importe venez voter pour nous à
l'élection primaire peut-être que vous
voterez pour la gauche à l'élection
présidentielle elle même parce que c'est
ça qui va se passer
moal électeurs de gauche qui décide
d'être à droite il a sa place dans la
primaire j'ai pas de problème il est
plus à gauche
donc il dit à droite jusqu'au bilan a
oui faut qu'il reste je voudrais super
celle qu'il faut pas qu'ils viennent
vous dites l'électeur de gauche n'a pas
à interférer dans la primaire de la
droite comme électeurs de droite
il n'a pas interféré dans la primaire de
la gauche parce que dans ce cas là il
faut pas faire de primaire dans ce cas
là ça veut dire qu'on est en train de
vie fier la primaire est donc de vicié
de de vicier les résultats
roger sont éventuellement j'ai pas dit
ça et 2 2 jusque là
laissez-moi les samoa et de vicier
l'élection présidentielle elle même donc
il faut faire très attention à ça si
nous faisons il faut de la déontologie
dans l'élection primaire et c'est pas un
problème la haute autorité au rite
autorités elles mécanique
s'ils vont sur la politique moi j'ai vu
tout mais j'ai quand même vu de d d d d
d d interview dans libération
c'est une drôle d'idée c'est vrai j'aime
beaucoup jean pierre a faim c'est un ami
c'est un ami personnel
mais faire une interview dans libération
c'est signé ça veut dire simplement fait
un appel du pied à l'électorat de gauche
libération d'un journal de gauche qui se
revendique à de bourges donc ça ne va
pas regarder un peu qu'ils allaient
voter à une primaire de la droite c'est
la primaire de la droite et c'est la
primaire du centre droit et si quelqu'un
veut venir voter ça veut dire qu'il
restera qui votera à droite
à ce moment là pour l'élection
présidentielle et pour être très clair
si les électeurs de gauche vont voter à
la primaire est ce que la primaire est
fausse et non mais moi je veux tout
faire pour me dire aucun enseignement
parce que si vous l'aimez à tirer pour
dire on va contester le résultat de la
génération moi je ne contesterai pas le
résultat de la primaire parce que dans
ce cas là je ne les contesterai
détesterait pas moi je voulais vraiment
d'accros à l'amiante je lis je ne tire
pas de conséquence de ce que je dis mais
je tire le sommet de la sonnette
d'alarmé que ça ne se passe pas moi je
suis j'ai dit d'accord comme beaucoup de
gens pour une primaire et je veux que
cette primaire ce soit la primaire de la
droite et du centre
c'est pas très original quand nathalie
kosciusko morizet voulait des signatures
pour se qualifier
deux députés socialistes on était
nombreux à dire nathalie tu te trompe
c'est enfin tu te trompes de primaires
l'a redit aussi ouvert s'est ouvert
s'est ouvert en temps ce temps sur sa
chaise comme ça ne s'est pas ouvert
s'est pas ouvert
gauche c'est la primaire de la droite et
du centre je suis même étonnée qu'on ait
besoin de l'expliquer c'est du bon sens
et si on veut des primaires chaque camp
fait ces primaires et puis après on fait
l'élection présidentielle avait
peut-être des avis parce que des proches
de françois hollande ont fait sortir un
petit papier en tout cas un petit
fascicule dans lequel il est marqué tout
ce qu'il pense qu'en mal d'alain juppé
sur son programme économique sur son
passé judiciaire
le but c'est de les décourager d'aller
voter à la primaire de droite c'est la
gorge de circonstance il ya aucune
alliance avec françois hollande parce
que ça c'est franchement ça peut vous
tirer vers le bas rhin une alliance avec
françois hollande ce serait avoir
absolument dramatique
françois hollande est un président
stagiaires on n'en veut plus personne
n'en veut plus il faut cette primaire
elle est sérieuse et moi je demande
qu'on y réponde
sérieusement si un électeur considèrent
qu'ils signent la charte de la primaire
on aurait dû faire une chars d'ailleurs
plus longue qui signe cette charte pour
dire je suis un électeur de droite c'est
ça que ça veut dire
cette jeune acteur de droite et du
centre pour que change is et si c'est le
cas et si le type ou là où la dame signe
cela c'est à dire qu elle le jure
et donc si elle le fait pas c'est
qu'elle est par jure donc attention à
cela
c'est très important pour la qualité de
la primaire notre primaire doit pas nous
échapper
on doit pas voler cette primaire aux
électeurs de la droite et du centre je
ne dis que cela mais suis même étonnée
d'avoir à le dire pour tout vous dire je
suis même étonné non fumeurs compris
nicolas sarkozy disait ce matin sur une
radio ne pas vouloir une alternance de
l'immobilisme et du compromis
on a compris qu'il vise alain juppé
c'est ça la jupe est celle immobilisé
mais il peut avoir des je pense que la
primaire elle est faite pour pour purger
des divergences immobilisme compromis
l'immobilisme c'est quoi compromis c'est
quoi je lui demanderais vous demanderez
nicolas sarkozy on voit bien qu'il ya
deux visions des choses beaucoup plus
on voit bien qu'on voit bien qu'il ya
deux visions des choses il ya une vision
plus forte c'est celle de nicolas
sarkozy dans le domaine de l'autorité
comme dans le domaine de l'économie par
exemple faire des dépenses en même temps
que la baisse de la fiscalité etc etc
donc il ya d'ailleurs d'ailleurs on dit
souvent qu'il kling moi je trouve ça
très bien il faut clivé clivé ça veut
dire décider clivé ça veut dire que on
peut pas s'arrêter sur des demi
solutions
et puis de l'autre et une vision plus
plus plus voilà plus soft plus douce de
d'alain juppé à chacun de s'exprimer
les deux visions ont leur doivent être
respectées
la primaire elle est faite pour qu'il y
ait des débats sur le fond donc allons
juste un loupé ces débats de quoi a
besoin la france
est-ce qu'elle a besoin de réformes
forte immédiate rapide puissante avec
une majorité solide mais qu'est ce que
je sais pas comment est ce que vous
allez séduire les autres candidats je
pense à tous ceux qui pourraient être
amenés à voter au deuxième tour pour
nicolas sarkozy
je pense des candidats à la primaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui ça a l'air quand
même plutôt pas dans ce sens là dans le
sens de l'histoire qu'un avis pourquoi
ce serait pas le cas c'est bien je suis
moi je crois aux dynamiques
si nicolas sarkozy retrouve une
dynamique
il en a eu une très forte il ya quinze
jours bon on s'y retrouve une dynamique
en un mois de campagne c'est évidemment
extrêmement possible et aucun doute là
dessus se retrouve une dynamique
le deuxième tour est très très
dépendants au point de cette dynamique
classique pour le deuxième débat est-ce
qu'il doit renverser la table au
deuxième débat non au deuxième d'abord
jean surya le deuxième débat c'est dans
dix ou quinze jours mais verra le
premier débat est un débat de bonne
qualité le 2 tendue et perdre aurait
d'abord j'ai pas remarqué qu'il avait
perdu le débat je pense qu'il est plus
tôt il a plutôt gagné je suis je
oui mais les avis des uns et des autres
ils sont totalement formater les avis
des uns et des autres ils sont
totalement formaté leur dénier à un
climat ya un vent voilà deux ans
seulement il faut être sur le terrain il
faut être près du peuple et du peuple
français
il fait lourd et inutile au paf oui mais
il fait des meetings pas s'ils
s'exposent
il se met en danger il ya peu de
candidats qui se met en danger et il a
raison de se mettre en danger
eric veulent être candidats pour la
france aujourd'hui arbres et ses 6
mètres en danger se mettre en danger ce
que font pas certains on l'a compris là
encore eric woerth que justement nicolas
sarkozy vous a rendu hommage lors de ce
premier débat des primaires il a évoqué
votre non lieu dans l'enquêté de la
vente de l'hippodrome de compiègne
aujourd'hui on apprend que l'homme court
plutôt si l affaire bettencourt avant la
mi-temps la relève d'affaires
bettencourt le nom là je pense à un non
lieu puisque cette affaire de
l'hippodrome de compiègne est elle
relancée la cour d'appel demande la
reprise de de l'anc est votre réaction
il ya déjà eu deux instructions une
quête duré quatre ans à la cour de
justice à contre cassette qui ont un
seul et même magistrat qui a conclu à un
non-lieu concernant c'était la partie
ministérielle
tout a été vu regardez c'est pas une
affaire c'est un dossier aujourd'hui
afin d'avoir des épaules quand il ya un
dossier
c'est une bagarre entre administrations
mes collaborateurs était haute et j'ai
emmené par un syndicat de gauche
d'ailleurs de l'eau nf qui aiment les
arbres commandant les aimer dans le
désert et cette saison était il ya eu un
non lieu prononcé par le juge
d'instruction après 3 ans et un non lieu
confirmé par le parquet il ya eu un
appel de ce non-lieu
ce non-lieu le la chambre d'instruction
a considéré qu'il fallait à supplément
d'instruction et un supplément la drogue
il fait quoi et bien ça fait quatre ans
qu'on est sur ce sujet c'est une honte
je vais vous le dire et donc ville c'est
une affiche aujourd'hui je me pose
beaucoup de questions tout cas une
persécution judiciaire là dessus sur ce
sujet c'est pas un sujet il n'y a pas de
sujet l'hippodrome de compiègne ça
n'existe pas tu as un bon dossier pour
l'état que maintenant la justice en
train de transformer en un mauvais
dossier pour l'état une image de coureur
indique cela me faire c'est jouer sur le
jeu on n'a pas réussi à atteindre on
veut attendre mes collaborateurs c'est
vraiment pas bien
merci à vous merci michael merci à tous
la semaine prochaine c'est michel sapin
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances qui sera à votre place qui sera
notre invité vent sera très vite
tous